I love that old Charles Bronson episode
of uh my name's Charles Bronson and I
feel
Surly about
be God that would be amazing that's in
we're using that as the opening but it
is not Charles Bronson in fact it is me
Bill hater and I feel tired about being
T Brian's friend it's a lot of work
isn't it it is a lot it's a lot of
lifting it's a lot of eye contact you've
moved me in and out of like six
Apartments
you still have that uh van don't you
yeah it's like hey Bill you still got
the van right can you help me
out well can you get
it God I love I I love a Charles Bronson
impression I really do it's Hank aer's
impression I just I do Hank AER as
Charles Bronson which I can't do but or
who was the guy Tim tomerson remember
that guy the he's really funny he was in
a bunch of movies in the 80s and there's
a he would do Charles Bronson uh he did
a president Charles Bronson and talking
to a a bag boy at a grocery store MH and
I remember watching that and he it just
started he he just he goes a zit
face I just wish I think people still
laugh CU I remember on The Simpsons we
had Charles Bronson on a couple times
the best once it was uh and Haner would
do the voice but it was a baby I
remember there was there was a little
boy yeah they went to Bronson Missouri
he went to Bronson Missouri and Sen of
Branson and everyone a version of
Charles Bronson and the little kid says
Hey Ma how about some cookies and uh the
the the Moss the mother says no dice and
and the kid says this isn't over this
ain't over this ain't over and it's the
best it's the hardest they they also
they and the when the critic came to
Springfield and it was like now uh we're
going to go to Death Wish nine and it
was Charles Bronson in a hospital bed he
goes I wish I was
dead I mean those are you know what's I
love Charles you know what's crazy uh
those movies the Death Wish movies don't
uh I know you're a movie buff so this is
a natural thing to go into but those
Death Wish movies don't really hold up
because in the I I remember they're made
in the 70s and it's all about how
basically it's it's just a they're wild
animals out there and you need to carry
a gun and people are getting killed left
and right and the police can't do
anything and then I remembered living in
New York in like the late '90s you know
all through the Late Night show which is
93 to whatever 2009 and and I remember
death wish came on and I was watching it
and someone said to the Charles Bronson
character come on it's really not that
bad out there and he says really have
you tried to walk north of Amsterdam on
75th and I thought
yeah there are seven places where you
can buy an a
clair yeah and that first movie starts
out like killing rapists and thieves and
then by the fourth one is just
jaywalkers he's picking off or weirdly
like people from the future like future
bodyguards or like weird Super Mario
Brother type of characters uh me and uh
one of the writers Matt we were watching
we just did it as a treat for ourselves
we watch one of the much later death
wishes and what happens is Charles
Bronson comes by New York to see his his
old friends this old couple and he lands
in the New York of 1988 or whatever you
know he lands in New York or he arrives
in the Port Authority he's on a bus he
gets off he gets in a cab and it's New
York and he starts driving north to the
northern part of Manhattan cut to this
moonscape they just and and apparently
they shot this part like in in England
but he gets to this moonscape of dirt
roads there's no more Paving and there's
wild gangs that just surround an
apartment building and they all of
course look like Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome with mohawks from New York
yeah and the police won't even go there
and you're you're thinking wait a minute
no I just saw you land in the New York
we all know and now it it felt like an
arch conservative ad for what New York
City is yeah I think that's exactly what
it is yeah that's exactly what it vote
for a
Dukakis is gold water still around this
is what's going to happen if you vote
for Dukakis everybody looks right at
camera